I moved to the project management office
at my company recently I found myself
managing a number of large projects
so doing a course in project management
became necessary for me my Decades of
experience and newly acquired skills
from the course helped me Excel and grow
professionally my earnings increased
significantly along with the new
responsibilities hi I'm ajaz Raul and
I'm the president of emorphosis LLC and
I live with my family in New Jersey I
came to the United States over three
decades ago to pursue a master's degree
in industrial engineering in fact I
started my career back in the 90s after
working for several Fortune 500
companies I started my own single person
consulting company called emorphosis LLC
as part of the project management office
I have been leading complex
multi-million dollar sap projects I
figured my work would be more effective
if I was well worsed and had mastered
the techniques of project management I
chose simply learn after a lot of
research and found that it offered a
combination of Life classes as well as
self-learning videos the PMP course
helped me prepare and pass the PMP
certification exam which was a
significant achievement the courses
helped me get ahead and stay ahead which
is important in my position it has
helped me lead the transformation at my
work
my Decades of experience and the newly
acquired skills also helped me increase
my earnings by about 20 percent
the best part about the course was its
flexibility and its availability on
various platforms I like the course so
much that I decided to pursue ACP agile
certified practitioner and agile scrum
Master courses from the same platforms
sometimes I studied while I was
traveling I watched self-learning videos
on my phone while I was walking my dog
I'm so glad I didn't stop learning I
used my experience to choose the right
job the right profile and the right
course thank you simply learn